what kind of food did you go out with
and well with mums at my mum's a social
worker and my dad used to be a musician
in the Air Force so right other than a
Sunday where we'd always have a roast
we'd always it all just be crap out the
freezer so sorry mum Margaret you tell
you tell me what your special is about
and I guarantee you I guarantee you the
angelou they'll disagree crap at the
freezer pancakes and stuff like that mum
Margaret was in this rude as a child was
he this rude as a child unbelievable now
okay big question yes Cook's the cordon
family Christmas dinner who is it I do
oh yeah truly no no honestly nowhere do
I like with no yeah mum me and mum
really but I take it so seriously
like honestly I start prepping on like
the 22nd all right Christmas Eve right
beef into the bowl
okay crush the garlic over the beef and
then from there put the tablespoons of
soy sauce
how have you got that much garlic are
there now just like a load I mean yeah
all right well that gourd you put in
then sorry right little bit of soy sauce
touch salt and pepper okay and then a
little bit of toasted sesame seed all
our beautiful this starts to marinate
the beef makes it really nice and tender
and more portly just starts to sort of
make it sort of delicious aromatic and
more importantly packed with flavor now
ginger take your stem of ginger the
medium-sized part of your grater
okay and just grate that sort of little
knob of ginger over the beef yeah now
this is the Philly steak and it's
marinating as we speak and the most
exciting thing about this particular cut
it cooks instantly when terms of flavor
delicious and absolutely perfect for
stir-fry and Mike's on it oh did you do
all that there
DISA Loomis that's fine Donna oh boy now
let's get all that out I like to use a
nice cord and I don't like to tap it
finally gets no leave that resting there
time now to slice our spring onions and
our chilies again same method with a
chili give that little rub okay
don't you mean see what was the rub it
rub it rub it rub it don't touch your
eyes well said Duncan for Peter Gabriel
seeds what did you do then
son [ __ ] how do you take it yeah no
audio oh hang on there we go
now slice that nice and finely okay
don't look at it chocolate spring your
knees together hold have you done the
chili yeah my mother loved cars watch
your fingers bring in his chili chopped
up nice and funny together now get those
in to the bowl now you're a very good
chopper you know that you can speak I
really like cooking I cook quite a lot
truly I really really love it well then
we'll then now spring on his chili in
with the peppers watch should be piping
hot now yes
first of all a tablespoon of ground nut
oil into the pan con James yes done say
well I'm bowing okami work with me once
you put in there then a tablespoon okay
of which one nut oil is that this one no
that salsa sauce which one okay that one
that's since I've session me one of each
sherry is Crowley good right go on
Sesame yeah that's me one tablespoon of
each in okay now get that really smoking
it's important now that we so do the
beef and we don't boil the beef roll
that round and he goes your beef all
right
okay now be careful nothing splashes
back into the wok
into the pan give that an occasional
stir